the Joe Rogan experience come on
Zionists you see that dude the dinero de
niro's was suing some lady that worked
for him that watched fifty five episodes
of friends in a week no yeah she
embezzled money allegedly embezzled
money took used his miles to fly on her
own personal trips making 300 grand a
year but the the big story the clickbait
title was uh he sued her for six million
dollars after a wild friends binge in
hey she watched 55 out of 55 episodes of
it in four days that's two thousand
eight so that's DVDs in 2008 that is
hilarious
so they're still going after it eleven
years later oh she began she was his
assistant in 2008 and then and then okay
she began as De Niro's assistant and she
now is being sued so she basically got
to a place where they're working
together for 11 years 11 years of
employment deniro robinson rose to
vice-president of production and finance
according to the suit which lists her
2019 salary three hundred thousand
dollars she finally left the company in
April after being suspected of corporate
sabotage said the legal filing she
embezzled money and she you know was
seven hours a day that's fourteen
episodes a day that's doable it's doable
yeah four days i benched twenty four in
like a day and a half the whole see yeah
a whole season back in a DVD box eight
days it was also a good show it's just
funny that out of all the [ __ ] that this
lady did apparently allegedly fifty five
episodes of friends are the ones that
became the headline that everybody had a
click on cuz that's a funny issues also
watch twenty episodes of Arrested
Development one day so just sit around
watching TV while she's working from
when she's supposed to be doing like
maybe she's doing research maybe she's
waiting around for something to do what
the narrow project needs friends
his research forecast Batman what's a
neo projects are even around I mean well
De Niro is probably trying to figure out
where all this money's going because
he's getting divorced right now so he's
probably yeah man he's getting divorced
there was a some public spat at a
restaurant where he yelled at his wife I
wouldn't have to do these shitty [ __ ]
movies if you weren't spending all my
money yeah oh I see that and I always
feel bad for people like the Cubs the
second baseman Ben Zobrist he's been
like I don't know what the Oh physically
unable to perform like he's basically
been on the disabled list the entire
season while he goes through and deals
with his divorce like divorce is some
serious [ __ ] even to go make millions of
dollars playing baseball I can't right
now I have to go to court and count my
cash and make sure that my [ __ ] is true
so his disabled [ __ ] is just dealing
with the divorce yeah it's I forget
money a real injury no it's not real
injury yeah well I guess technically
that's a girl taking apart his puzzle
yeah she's doing she's taking apart the
puzzle of his life yeah she's forcing
him to go through I think it was like
infidelity or something yeah I had a
buddy of mine who he had to pay for his
wife's lawyer you don't even think about
it that way like if you're married you
go well who's paying for her lawyer well
[ __ ] you're paying for her lawyer if
she didn't work you pay for the general
of the opposing army to try to dismantle
you financially he didn't have a
prenuptial agreement so he went to my
boy for [ __ ] years years and years
and years and they were trying to drain
them and the lawyers are smart man they
know that the real settlement is great
but what the real money is is in legal
fees leading up to the settlement this
dragged that [ __ ] out for a couple of
years hundreds of dollars an hour ching
ching ching and next thing you know
you've lost millions of dollars and this
guy you know busted his ass 12 hours a
day forever lost almost everything still
to this day how about this he's been
married for I think he's been married
for 14 years to a new woman he was with
her for 12 years and he has been paying
her alimony long
than they were married while he's
married to a new woman and didn't even
have kids with her so he's been paying
her for 14 [ __ ] years I'm talking six
figures every year she doesn't do [ __ ]
she lives in a fat house in the
Palisades the whole thing is bananas